There has been an awakening.
Have you felt it?
*Panicked beeps*
The Darkside...
and the Light...
*StarWars Theme Music*
Hey Youtubers, It's Charlie. So no surprise here,
they're doing Lego Episode 7.
But the really cool thing is that there's ganna be content that 'ill
bridge the gap between Return of the Jedi and Episode 7.
If you saw the Lego Movie or you played any of the other Lego games,
Like they even did a DC Lego games.
Stephen Amell did his voice for Green Arrow.
"Stranded on an island with only one goal. Survive."
"To survive I must become someone else"
"Something..green...and pointy"
"...and Arrow-y"
You can kind of think of this as a playable comedy version of Star Wars Episode 7.
Now, obviously there's ganna be a lot of tripple A games
based on the new movies, so if you're a bigger fan of the
traditional game presentation, the traditional type of narratives,
then they'll have those too.
This seems more like the tongue-in-cheek Star Wars gaming you'd play
in the middle of finals or if you have like a ton of work,
Something that isn't ganna wind up being the most difficult game you've ever played in your entire life.
Just something fun to blow a couple hours on.
So if you're strapped for cash I wouldn't worry about buying it.
and yeah, I'm ganna buy it. I'll totally play it,
but I'm probably mostly going to be using it for comedy gifs.
That's kind of where I'm at with a lot of Episode 7 stuff right now,
where I've seen it a couple, thought all the thoughts,
looked for all the Eater Eggs, and now is the time for turning it into really weird art.
And using it for comedy with other mash ups.
If  your not on Facebook, thats actually where I post most of that stuff
Those little small videos are actually my most fun thing to do
when I'm not making big videos for the YouTube channel.
Important stuff though; of course they got all the actors
to do their voices for their characters.
It's probably part of their contracts, like if you do this we'll pay you extra money,
but it'll be a seamless experience of the audience.
It won't be some weird person voicing your character.
It's dropping on all consoles, PC, everywhere- on June 28th.
We'll call that 'Shut Up and Take My Money Day'.
But in related news, I know a lot of you wondering about Star Wars Rouge 1.
Are they ganna drop a teaser soon? Is there ganna be a Super Bowl teaser?
I'm not expecting it, I don't think LucasFilm really needs to spend the money for a Super Bowl ad.
That doesn't mean that they won't do anything for Super Bowl Sunday.
There might be some Star Wars content.
But what I'm really expecting is that they'll attach a Rouge 1 trailer of some sort
to Captain America: Civil War
You have to remember that Disney owns all these companies now,
so a lot of the new things that they drop for Star Wars, Marvel things, they're all grouped together.
Big Marvel movie comes, the thought is that ya know,
most of those people, probably also like Star Wars.
So, We'll put some Star Wars with this too.
But that doesn't mean that we're not ganna get any Rouge 1 stuff,
It just means that I'm not expecting any this weekend.
If there is, I will totally do a video for it,
if there is any Star Wars related stuff.
I'm mostly just expecting Marvel and Fox stuff.
Like there's supposed to be some Deadpool (Hi!- D.P.),
X-Men Apocalypse, Captain America Civil War,
not excpecting any Doctor Strange but  just stay tuned
and there will be more Star Wars this week, non-Lego Star Wars.
I want to do a Captain Phasma video.
I need to do a Rouge 1 video, it's a little harder to do Rouge 1 videos
because we haven't really seen any footage from it yet.
But be sure to Subscribe to get everything,
If there is any special Star Wars stuff that you guys want this week, just let me know in the comments
Speaking of Captian America: Civil War, if you guys haven't seen it
I just did a Scarlet Witch-Vision video, you can click here to watch that
and you can click here for my X-Files video from last night.
Thank you so much for watching, everybody lets high-five, I'll see you guys tonight.